>> WELCOME BACK TO THE
EXAMINER'S SHOW.
HILLARY CLINTON STILL CANNOT LET
HER ELECTION LAWS GO SHE IS NOT
LAMENTING WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN
BY BELTING OUT TUNES LIKE I WILL
SURVIVE ALONG WITH HER DAUGHTER,
ACTRESS VANESSA WILLIAMS AND
COMEDIAN AMBER ON APPLE TV PLUS.
♪ GO WALK OUT THE DOOR ♪
♪ JUST TURN AROUND NOW ♪
♪ ♪
♪ I WILL SURVIVE ♪
>> WILL IT TAKE FOR HILLARY TO
FINALLY MOVE ON?
SHE HAS RULED OUT THE 2024 RUN
YET RIGHT I DON'T KNOW THAT I
BELIEVE THAT, WITH HER
PERFORMANCE ON CARPAL KARAOKE
HILLARY IT SHOWS SHE'S STILL NOT
OVER HER FAILED PRESIDENTIAL
ASPIRATIONS.
SHE IS NOT GOING AWAY ISSUE.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE CRITICIZED THE CLINTONS.
THEY WISH THEY HAD SURVIVED.
IT WAS SOMETHING WHEN SHE HELD
ONTO THE SELECTION LOSS AND SAID
HE WAS A DILIGENT PRESIDENT
STACY ABRAM SEND ME COMMENTS I'M
RUNNING WHEN SHE'S NOT A CAR
SINCE SHE WAS SHE HAD SURVIVED
AS WELL.
NOTHING IN THE SAME OLD TRASH
AND WITHOUT A HAND IT BACK TO
YOU.
>> HARRIS, SHE SANG ALL THE
RIGHT THINGS BUT I HEAR GAVIN
NEWSOM I HEAR THEM ALL SING THE
RIGHT THING ABOUT WE SUPPORT NO
BITING.
IN THE MOMENT HE'S NOT GOING TO
RUN OR STEPS AWAY, DO YOU THINK
HILLARY CLINTON IS REALLY GOING
TO PARK IT OFF SOME THINGS THAT
HAVE NOT CHANGED ABOUT HER MAY
KEEP HER OUT AGAIN.
IS SHE SINGING WITH HER
GIRLFRIENDS INSIDE THE CORPORAL
CARPAL KARAOKE IS NOT
ENGENDERING THE SPIRIT OF WOMEN
FOR THEM TO SUPPORT YOU.
SHE HAS NOT HAD A HUGE FEMALE
BASE.
IT'S GOING TO DIFFICULT IF SHE
WERE DECIDE ELECTION DENIER
ENGLISH LIKE TO ARGUE SHE GOT
MORE VOTES.
IN CASE I DON'T LIKE YOU CAN
LEGISLATE ALL THE WAY BACK THAT
FAR.
NOBODY ELSE SAW THAT HAPPEN BUT
HER IF THAT IS HER PREMISE.
BUT RIGHT NOW I DO NOT KNOW WHAT
LIKE SHE HAS TO STAND ON.
WHO HASN'T THINK JOE BIDEN IS
NOT RUNNING?
HE KEEPS SORT OF TELLING US WHEN
HE CAN REMEMBER HE IS SUPPOSED
TO.
WHEN IT TELLS ABOUT HIS WIFE WHO
SAYS MAY LEAVE THEM AS
POLITICALLY WRONG AS IT WAS HE
WENT INTO THIS WHOLE STORY ABOUT
RESERVATIONS HOW SHE MIGHT GO
LIVE ON ONE OF HE DOES NOT WIN,
WHAT WAS THAT?
>> IVER DIFFERENT EXHIBIT
HILLARY CLINTON.
I DON'T THINK SHE WAS RUNNING
2024.
I THINK SHE WANTS TO BE A
CELEBRITY.
THIS IS HER ON THAT.
SHE IS HOCKING HATS ON INSTAGRAM
THIS WOMAN WAS TO BE AN
INFLUENCER THAT IS WHAT IS AT
THIS POINT.
I THINK SHE KNOWS HER POLITICAL
CAREER IS OVER.
EVERYONE HAS HILLARY FATIGUE
KIND OF LIKE WE HAVE COVID
FATIGUE.
SHE LIKELY FRUITCAKE CHRISTMAS
THAT WILL NEVER GO AWAY NOW SHE
REALLY SHE CAN FLIP A BUCK ON
THIS AND SHE WAS BEEN
INFLUENCER.
IT'S A MATTER OF TIME BEFORE HE
STARTS FEELING HILLARY CLINTON
WITH FAD FIT COMING TO INSTAGRAM
NEAR YOU.
I DON'T ABSENT HILLARY CLINTON'S
HAS EVER BEEN MENTION THE SAME
THING BUT HASH TAG ADD.
I GOT COMING FOR YOU.
>> LOOK AT THIS LITTLE MONTAGE
OF HER COMPLAINING, HAVE A LOOK.
>> WHAT ABOUT ENDEMIC SEXISM AND
MASSAGE IT NOT JUST IN POLITICS
BUT IN OUR SOCIETY.
>> YOU CAN RUN THE BEST
CAMPAIGN.
YOU CAN EVEN BECOME THE NOMINEE.
AND YOU CAN HAVE THE ELECTION
STOLEN FROM YOU.
>> IS LIKE APPLYING FOR A JOB
GETTING 66 MILLION LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION AND LOSING TO A
CORRUPT HUMAN AND TORNADO.
I'M GOING TO FACE ON A MOST
PUBLIC DEFEATS HEAD ON MY
SHARING WITH YOU THE SPEECH I
HAD HOPED TO DELIVER IF I HAD
WON THE 2016 ELECTION.
AND AS HARD AS IT MIGHT BE TO
IMAGINE, YOUR DAUGHTER WILL GROW
UP AND BECOME THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
[LAUGHTER]
IS LIKE YOUR EXIT BREAKS UP WITH
YOU AND JASON TEASES ME WHEN I
WAS SINGLE IN MY 20, YOU DO AN
EXIT INTERVIEW YOU TRY TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT WENT WRONG.
I WAS SINGLE FOREVER OKAY?
>> HILLARY CLINTON IS GETTING
VERY CLOSE TO COME VERY CLOSE TO
SOME FATAL ATTRACTION TYPE STUFF
THERE.
BIG AGAIN I'M TELLING YOU
BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO BE US
CELEBRITY PENDING DANCING WITH
THE STARS IS THE NEXT.
>> I HOPE I SURVIVE THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
WORKS THAT IF SHE CAN DANCE, WE
DO NOT KNOW.
>> OH WE KNOW, WE KNOW.
>> HOLLYWOOD CELEBRITIES ARE
STILL PROMOTING HER.
THEY STILL SAY SHE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN THE PRESIDENT.
WITH THAT CONSIDERATION THERE
ARE SOME SANG SOME WOMEN AND MEN
ARE ACTUALLY SAYING THEM.
>> OVER KAMALA HARRIS THOUGH?
>> IS COMPLICATED.
>> 'S 2016 NOT RIGHT NOW.
WITH THIS SHE CONTINUES TO GET
EVERY BUCK SHE CAN GOOD ON HER
TO TRY TO GET MONEY.
BECAUSE I DO THINK TOM IS
PROBAB